I mean there's a lot of debate in the
scientific literature about the meaning
of dreams and perhaps there's even
debate about whether it's possible for
dreams to have meaning I think partly
the debate exists because to do dream
analysis properly as Union particularly
you need a vast body of knowledge in the
dream interpreter about comparative
mythology and ritual and symbol and and
art history and so forth because dreams
of course use images as their primary
means of conceptualization now in order
to understand what what dreams mean and
how they can be useful in therapy apart
from appreciating the fact that the
interpreter needs a broad body of
knowledge that scientists generally
don't develop it's also important to
know what it is that scientists have
discovered about dreams so for example
we know that dreams occur during rapid
eye movement sleep you cycle into rapid
eye movement sleep about every 90
minutes when you're asleep when you're
in rapid eye movement sleep your motor
centers so your action centers are very
much activated in your brain but your
body is paralyzed so that you can't move
around your eyes are moving because of
course it doesn't really matter if your
eyes move while you're asleep because
they won't take you anywhere but if your
legs were moving while you were asleep
you run into walls while you were
dreaming and scientists have actually
managed to damage the motor inhibition
systems in cats so that they do move
around when they're dreaming anyways if
you wake up when someone's dreaming
their brain is about as active as it is
when they're awake so there's a
tremendous amount of journal processing
going on in the dream state if you wake
someone up when they're dreaming there's
about an 80% chance that they'll report
the emotion of anxiety dreams tend to
focus on threat
now a threat is anything that might hurt
you but it's more than that - a threat
is anything that doesn't fit into your
current conceptual scheme you imagine
that you have a theory about the way the
world is and then you act on that theory
and sometimes things work out the way
you'd like them to work out but often
they don't and every time things work
out in a way that isn't how you would
like or how you predicted that indicates
that there's some more about the world
that you have to learn about and that
fact first manifests itself in anxiety
now the dream focuses on anxiety and
then it loosens up it's the normal
conceptual constraints that characterize
waking thinking and it starts to play in
a sense or hypothesize about how your
current categorical structure could be
shifted around so that that threat could
be accounted for
okay now that means the dream is dealing
with things that you need to understand
but you don't yet understand so when you
wake up and you remember the dream the
dream doesn't really make sense because
it's about something you don't
understand
now it's your brains best guess at
configuring or understanding the
unknowable but it's like it's it's like
the first layer of a multi-layered
process which eventually would culminate
in fully developed thought maybe over
months or maybe over years or maybe you
would never manage it at all the unknown
thing or the threat is just too great to
really come to any terms with it
whatsoever okay now I imagine that
you're dreaming about something and it
produces enough emotion what the threat
produces enough emotion not only to
produce a very vivid dream but to wake
you up when you wake up you remember the
dream and then you will tell someone
about it well the dream is about
something you don't yet understand that
that's upsetting and if you tell a bunch
of people about it they're going to give
you all sorts of opinions on the dream
and that's a way that you can gather
more information about the threat are we
talking
about an extreme case which is known as
a nightmare
or perhaps simply a dream which is
faintly troubling all puzzling because
it's so abstract could you differentiate
between I think I think it's clearer in
the case of nightmares and often too
because nightmares tend to have
archetypal themes you know people for
example are often threatened by monsters
in nightmares and a monster is a chimera
that's made up of the different parts of
different parts of frightening things a
dragon is a chimera for example because
it's made out of reptilian parts and it
also includes the idea of fire and
transformation so a nightmare is a dream
that tends to use archetypal imagery to
conceptualize a fairly powerful threat
and if you recount a nightmare to a
person with no specific training they're
going to have some opinion about it and
their opinion might be useful in terms
of information Katherine but if you
recount a dream to someone who's
psychologically trained and is also
symbolically trained and who has you
know great great depth of knowledge with
regards to the structure of religious
thinking and and comparative literature
the light that they're going to shed on
your dream is much brighter and and more
profound and sometimes a dream
interpretation can offer the person
who's had the dream a leap forward in
knowledge that might have taken them
five or six years to conceptualize by
themselves an insight you might say that
they wouldn't normally have had because
the person who's the expert who's had
the dream recounted to them knows and
says ah yes I know of that place that
they say they've been to that experience
they've had that symbol and its meaning
and above all what it feels like because
surely it is some people say that me
included that one way to interpret a
dream when you wake up is to just like
you would taste a sip of wine just hold
the flavor and and hold the feeling what
does it feel like and
what does fear what feels the same in
your real life and that's what the
dreams trying to tell you with a collage
of symbols and memories as well that is
drawn on in recent conscious experience
to try and put it together hence the
dream can be a very abstract would you
say that's the case sometimes well I
think there's two things about about
your comments that are really worth
highlighting the first is the category
is that a dream uses are generally based
on emotional similarity rather than
logical similarity yes so a dream for
example might represent fear or the fear
of something unknown by using a
juxtaposition of a variety of images of
frightening things so imagine that in
the dream world the basic rule is all
things that produce the same emotion are
the same thing and so your description
of a dream interpretation process that
relies on identifying similarities in
emotional state gets right to the core
of how dream thought works now
secondarily I also believe that if you
are able to help someone
construct a dream interpretation that
fits they're also able to feel that it
fits it clicks or it makes sense or it's
like the punchline of a joke in some way
they can tell that the interpretation
has put some missing pieces of the
puzzle into place and I think it's
important to rely on that as an
indicator of whether the interpretation
is actually derived from the dream or
sort of just a theoretical imposition on
its structure now we can go underneath
that too and I mentioned already that
basic categories are more
action-oriented than object-oriented so
basic categories the basic categories of
the human mind are categories to do
things with well by the same token there
are also motivational and emotional
categories so the primordial mind like
the animal mind thinks sort of
axiomatically
that all things that produce
the same emotion are the same thing so
there's things that make you happy or
there's things that make you sad or
there's things that make you anxious and
the fact that all those things share the
capacity to evoke that emotion speaks of
some ESET essential identity between
them now the identity is in relationship
to the experiencer and not necessarily
with regards to similarity between the
objects but it's still how we naturally
think and it's certainly how mythology
thinks and it's how drama thinks and how
religion thinks and we've lost sight of
that in part because we've become
scientifically trained to some degree
and we tend to believe that the real
categories of the world are objective
and all right that that just strikes me
as it's wrong there's something about it
that's wrong and it's wrong because we
have to act